por segundo día consecutivo los
ucranianos despertaron con el sonido de
sirenas y nuevos bombardeos misiles
golpearon el pueblo suroriental de
zaporilla a la mañana de este martes
hubo dos explosiones luego una tercera
fue fuerte las cosas volaban por allá
corría el pasillo los niños lloraban mi
nieto lloraba
Mientras tanto las autoridades afirmaban
que las instalaciones centrales energía
de Ucrania habían sufrido serios daños
parte de la ciudad del VIP quedó sin
electricidad luego de los bombardeos el
martes el ministro de defensa de Rusia
confirmó los ataques que también
golpearon las ciudades es solo bianks y
ni Pro
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continuaron hoy un masivo ataque
aéreo y marítimo con armas de precisión
de largo alcance contra el control
militar ucraniano e instalaciones del
sistema energético
todo esto después de que muscular más de
80 misiles en ciudades por todo Ucrania
incluyendo la capital el día lunes la
Oficina de derechos humanos en Naciones
Unidas expresó preocupaciones de que los
ataques de Rusia están dirigidos a
infraestructura civil vital y que estos
Podrían haber violado las leyes de la
guerra debemos señalar esta
intencionalidad ataques dirigidos contra
civiles y objetivos civiles Eso
significa objetivos que no son militares
equivalente a un crimen de guerra
el bombardeo de Moscú lleguen aparente
retaliación una explosión de un puente
clave que une a Rusia con la anexionada
Península de crimea el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin culpó Ucrania y advirtió
de severas respuestas a futuros ataques